[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the economics correspondent at The
Spectator Kate Andrews and the political
editor at the post UK Kevin Schofield so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
well the mail leads with the news that a
body has been found by police searching
for Nicola bully less than a mile from
where she vanished
the times says divers were deployed to
an outcrop of trees and reeds in the
river wire after two Walkers called the
police
the eye also leads with the body being
found in the river near where the mum of
two went missing
it's also on the front of the Metro
which reports the 45 year old's family
are being comforted
the financial times reports that
Poland's president is calling on NATO to
give Ukraine a post-war security
guarantees just prior to the U.S
president's visit to Warsaw this week
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Kate
Andrews and Kevin Schofield uh thank you
both for taking us through the papers
let's start with the metro and um well
very sad story uh following on from the
the story of Nicola bully going missing
a body has been found this evening in
the river wire
Kate
as you say a very sad story already is
potentially taking an even more
upsetting twist the body of a woman has
been found about roughly a half a mile
from where Nicola bully is thought to
have gone missing it's the body of a
woman it should be stressed that it's
not yet identified but there are reports
in the papers uh going into tomorrow
that the family is being comforted to
prepare for the possibility that it is
uh Nicola there's again a lot of
backlash and criticism about police
handling of the situation so far
questions already as to how this has
gone overlooked it sounds like there is
a call from Walkers who stumbled upon
what appeared to be a woman's body
potentially how this went missing and
what has been a very wide reaching
search so far so there's still plenty of
questions on the table but that original
theory that perhaps she fell into the
river or ended up in the river seems to
be getting some traction this evening as
this body has been found yes and Kevin
the Metro reporting that the police
force is now likely to face even more
questions over why her body wasn't found
despite repeated searches in the river
yeah exactly it's over three weeks now
since Nicola bully went missing there's
obviously been extensive
um set she's going on in the area the
police very quickly said that they
suspected that she may have gone into
the water so you wonder exactly how
um the body has taken so long for a body
to be found as as Katie said they know
it's not been confirmed yet that it is
Nicola bully but
um certainly the police are already
under a lot of pressure for the way that
they've conducted this investigation and
you know this could potentially lead to
to further further questions but at the
end of the day you know your thoughts
just go out to our family it's been a
traumatic few weeks for them they've
been at the in the eye of a media storm
really
um and it's just been heart-wrenching to
to follow it and um and yeah it looks as
though it's going to come to
particularly sad
um ending yes the Home Secretary in the
AI being quoted as saying that this
development is heartbreaking that's the
quote although it has to be said Kate
that there has not been a formal
identify identification at this point
yeah that's really important to stress
you know these details there a lot of
them are are yet to be confirmed and and
so we don't want to jump to any
conclusion
um but you know almost regardless of
what that finds you know a family and
and two children are still missing their
mother
um and they are preparing for the worst
as this situation develops and as Kevin
points out they've had to deal with some
horrible things over the past few weeks
you know of course even putting aside
the fact that their mother has gone
missing they've had to deal with the
police sharing very personal details
about Nikola Boley and the potential
status of her mental health which as far
as they can tell so far you know really
should not have been put into the public
domain there's no particular reason to
do that you know this is already a
tragic case
um and you know those suggestions almost
seem like it was a bit of a cover-up for
why the police were taking so long and
put the emphasis back on Nicola and her
family and and again you know tonight
there are going to be questions as to
why the police have taken so long to
find this body which is not confirmed
yet but you know it's still a very bad
sign that it wasn't uncovered to begin
with so
um you know there's there's going to be
a lot of emphasis on the police and our
hearts just have to go out to the bully
family at this time as they wait for
further news
yes Kevin as and as Kate says the force
highly criticized over releasing into
the public domain those personal details
uh the the Prime Minister was concerned
about that information being in the
public domain as as was the Home
Secretary
yeah that show it's become a political
story as well I think Kirsten also
expressed concern about um those those
details being released into the public
domain it was it was a surprise
certainly it struck me as quite unusual
now there have been suggestions that the
family were aware that this was that
this was going to happen
um and you know that slightly puts a a
different gloss on it but regardless you
know it has has been obviously a
traumatic experience for the family and
for these personal details to be
released and would have been
particularly unpleasant as well so you
know once the investigation
um or once the um investigation reaches
a conclusion I think there will be
serious questions still to be answered
by the police forces to how they have
conducted themselves and conducted this
inquiry and they've obviously come under
a lot of a lot of scrutiny and factors
as you see that the Home Secretary and
the premise are both raised concerns
about how they've gone about their
business means that I think this will
rumble on for quite some time indeed
let's move on to uh some politics and
this being the post-brexit trade deal
with with Northern Ireland accusations
that that Boris Johnson is trying to
escape her which she soon acts uh
attempts at reaching a deal let's have a
look at the uh the metro to start with
on that story Kate
so we have two recent former prime
ministers in the conservative party who
both perhaps feel in their own ways that
they were ousted too soon I'm of course
speaking about Boris Johnson and Liz
trust and we had the big list trust
intervention just last a few weeks ago
when she was talking about why she still
thinks her plan for growth is the right
one and going into tomorrow we have uh
Boris Johnson warning that uh if Rishi
sunak were to make changes to the
Northern Ireland protocol bill that he
quote masterminded
um that that could be a real detriment
to the brexit that he secured now I mean
this really brings us back to the the
politics of brexit uh but you know there
has been pretty Universal recognition
that the Northern Ireland protocol has
not been working as was once hoped the
way that Boris Johnson secured it that
having to check goods between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland has really
had a detrimental impact on the
residents of Northern Ireland and Boris
Johnson proposed this bill and the idea
behind it was that actually the UK would
be able to chip it way a chip away parts
of the protocol that weren't working
Rishi sunak has been hoping to avoid
that he wants to come to a New Deal a
better compromise with Brussels and the
idea behind it is that fewer if any
Goods would need to be checked but
perhaps the European court of justice
would still have a role to play and and
that's a tough that's a tough thing to
argue with some brexiteers
um but it's interesting going into
Monday you have the times reporting that
Rishi sunak is ready to push ahead you
have the telegraph saying that he's
putting this on pause there's clearly a
lot of confusion over what's going to
happen with something that Rishi sunak
wanted to report on as early as this
week but there's no doubt that whenever
he's trying to secure is going to cause
problems within the Tory party and it
does seem now that Boris Johnson in
particular is perhaps ready to have that
battle with the current prime minister
yes indeed and uh cabinet minister Penny
Morden Tom Sophie Ridge on Sunday
described Boris Johnson's intervention
as not completely unhelpful that that
was her description this morning um or
what say you Kevin
I mean I think they're actually trying
to kill Boris Johnson with kindness
there I mean he made his intervention to
be as unhelpful as possible
um he clearly is not a big fan of Rishi
sunaki how many supporters blame British
sunak for beginning the process which
ultimately brought down Boris Johnson
and he would dearly love to replace him
again as prime minister and he sees this
issue of Bob brexit as something
um that he can use to undermine Rishi
sunak
um you know I think what penny modern
was was trying to do was trying to sort
of dismiss the significance of what
Boris Johnson was saying you can
understand when she's going out to bat
for the government it's not a
particularly pleasant experience
sometimes when you're having to deal
with negative stories like this but yeah
there's there's no doubt that it's it is
unhelpful for Rishi sunai it doesn't
need Boris Johnson on his case as well
as the dup and the other brexiteers the
the ERG group of conservative and PS
um as Kate said you know last week
towards the end of last week the noises
were particularly optimistic about this
deal and there was talk about it being
introduced to Parliament tomorrow a
debate and a vote on Tuesday it's
looking as though that may well slip a
little bit I still think that something
will be agreed this week but then that's
only half the battle as I said you know
he's hoping to get the dup on board so
that they will go back into
um or they were entering a per sharing
agreement gets storming up and running
again alongside Shen Fein and there's as
I say these ERG members who are also
um very keen that uh that um sovereignty
is their sort of key watchword as far as
the brexit deal is concerned anything
which allows the European court of
justice to still have some kind of say
in the Affairs of Northern Ireland I
think we don't particularly badly with
them so it's a really difficult balance
in that the Prime Minister has got he
will present a deal but we'll just see
how it goes down and as we say Boris
Johnson is always willing to be as
unhelpful as possible just along from
the pictured Bose Johnson and Penny
Morden is so Kia starmer and the story
there I just want to drop in quickly
that the labor leaders urging SNP voters
to put their faith in his party in the
wake of Nicholas sturgeon's resignation
what do you think his chances are of
that happening Kate
um look I think this is the shot labors
out of Scotland for quite some time
Nicholas surgeon regardless of what you
think of her politics was a real
political force to be reckoned with and
there's a sense that the SMP might lose
some of their support and some of their
focus and that her resignation was
almost an admission not quite but almost
in a mission that the current fight for
independence is not going in the
direction that the SMP want
um and then of course if you look at the
smp's record on their domestic issues
especially around the NHS in education
there's a lot of room for another party
to come in and say put your faith in us
in for so long it it was the
conservatives that were providing that
opposition labor would have a big way to
jump in Scotland but they see this as
their opportunity
um and you know there's there's an
understandable reason to think that
kiosama thinks this is moment to make
the pitch Kevin it's okay Stormer saying
that the road to electoral success must
run through Scotland
yeah I mean historically if if you look
after anything that labor have formed
the government at Westminster they have
also sent down
um very many uh labor MPS from Scotland
right now they've only got one so
clearly if they get even a dozen say for
argument's sake that would make things a
little bit easier for them they wouldn't
have to win quite so many seats in
England in order to form the next
government but you know losing Nicholas
doesn't is is one thing I think a lot of
hinges on who she is replaced with and
the appeal that that person has but you
know a lot of Labor and labor supporters
in Scotland switched to the SNP in the
wake of the independence referendum in
2014. it's not a given that they will
just suddenly switch back or a good
number of them will switch back just
because Nicholas studsen has Departed
the scene so uh so labor have still got
a lot of work to do but certainly as
Kate says they're in a much stronger
position in Scotland now than they have
been for many many years interesting
Kevin and Kate for the moment thank you
we are going to take a break but coming
up
we'll take a look at the front of the
financial times it's headline Poland
calls for NATO to guarantee Ukraine's
security after end of War stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me the economics
correspondent at The Spectator Kate
Andrews and the political editor at tap
post UK Kevin Schofield welcome back to
both of you let us have a look at the
financial times and this story about
Poland's intervention in the war in
Ukraine um they're saying that NATO
needs to give Ukraine post-war security
and this is the president of Poland Duda
ahead of a a visit by Joe Biden to
Warsaw okay take us into this story
so this story comes ahead of as you say
President Joe Biden's visit to Warsaw
this week uh to recognize the the first
year anniversary of Russia's Invasion
against Ukraine the most recent one I
should say
um and Paula's leader president Duda is
calling on Joe Biden to commit to
essentially a security guarantee there's
wide understanding that Ukraine cannot
join NATO at this time
um but essentially that there would be
an extension and a different structure
to the agreement in which if Russia were
to keep attacking Ukraine or attack
Ukraine in the future that the U.S and
other countries such as France would
sign up to support them militarily and
to give them weapons and to give them
support now something like this has
actually been played down in the Munich
security conference over the weekend by
the U.S by German officials according to
the Ft
um that you know arguing that they don't
want to preempt anything and argue are
trying to de-escalate a little bit to
see where more areas of compromise might
be found but the idea here is that
President Duda really wants Joe Biden
um to reaffirm that NATO's Article 5 in
the US's commitment to it that one
attack on a NATO country is an attack on
them all surely Joe Biden is not going
to hesitate to do that the question is
whether or not he would then extend and
say that Ukraine would have this special
structure in which NATO countries would
come to its defense as well he might be
fearful that that could escalate the
situation
yes we read that some NATO nations are
remaining wary of binding promises uh
that being for fear of being dragged
into a war with Russia and instead
they're arguing for strengthening
Ukraine's military in instead to ensure
that they can defend themselves
yeah which is obviously what is going on
right now you know some countries are
more enthusiastic about it than others
as we know but yeah I mean this
um as Kate says the story makes clear
that there is an acceptance that
um Ukraine can't be a full member of
NATO at least not at this particular
moment in time but this would give them
a special status effectively whereby in
future they would be given the
protection of NATO without being a fully
fledged NATO Country Now obviously this
comes out a very
um a difficult time right now clearly
and the support has been given to
Ukraine to help them fight Russia but at
the same time there's a weirdiness
among Western countries that they don't
want to escalate tensions and provoke
Russia even further but I think yeah I
think it'll be quite difficult really
for
um for the West to reject this
particular suggestion I think at the
moment it would it would effectively I
think be quite a sensible compromise
between the current situation and
full-blown NATO membership okay we've
heard for some time that uh Putin might
want to extend at this one Russia's now
being blamed for tensions in Moldova
what's been happening there
this is a really interesting ft front
cover going into Monday because you have
one country ordering Paul at boarding
Ukraine Poland the story we just talked
about now you have another country board
in Ukraine Moldova where today protests
have been taking place organized by the
pro-russia party
um trying to ouster demand the
resignation of what's considered to be
their pro-west president
Sandu and some are arguing that you know
this is actually a plot by Russia to try
to destabilize
um the the party in Moldova is pushing
back on that but you're seeing really
different aspects to reaction especially
in the region about this ongoing
invasion of Ukraine
um and it is also a reminder that the
politics and the bordering countries are
very very different
um and the demands that are taking place
are different as well and and this all
adds into the mix of a very messy
situation
um and there's no sign at the moment
that Russia does plan to de-escalate in
fact Ukraine has obviously been
preparing um for a far worse scenario in
the coming months and it is just that
reminder of court that they still need
which president zielinski was adamant
about over the weekend in Munich Kevin
you've got about 30 seconds Moscow have
denied these claims but they have denied
very many other things
well yeah they would do that wouldn't
they um you take what they see with a a
healthy dose of salt um yeah it just
shows that the potential there for this
um uh dispute or this uh conflict to
escalate elsewhere in the region is
acute and you know it is it's something
that the West particularly does not want
it to spill out over outside Ukraine's
borders but you know there is obviously
as things continue to escalate there is
always that potential and it's something
that um that the West officer has to
keep a very close eye on Okay Kevin and
Kate thank you both we'll see you in the
next hour thank you